rugby a town of 70,000 in the West
Midlands a shop selling Polish goats has
opened on the high street
like other towns and cities across
Britain rugby is home to many immigrants
from other EU member states at the
market people are skeptical of Europe we
want should be owned also at the end of
the day nothing it's made in this
country anymore everything's imported
overseas I think that should the
regulars at the bullpup have already
downed a few pints they also have
nothing good to say about the EU coming
over here you know I mean we'll give you
another third wheel country they
overpopulated by immigrants and that's
why I don't want to look do that's why I
don't agree in Europe
I just come out of it only the young
people of rugby a keen to remain in the
EU I think it's good to stay anyway
there's like a big family like if we
leave it's almost like we're not got a
family anymore
but now software company Hall of as'
which has its headquarters a few
kilometres out of town is trying to
convince people of the benefits of EU
membership they're currently working on
some very interesting game development
work Andrew Brown is strategy director
at hala vez the firm is growing so he
wants to be able to recruit IT foreign
specialists without much red tape six
people from other EU countries currently
work here we find obviously EU
recruitment the easiest of all because
we know that the people have a right to
work in the UK from day one it's more
complicated working with other
jurisdictions because we have to go
through the work visa process Johan from
Mumbai India is interning at hallo
the firm plans to hire him once he's
graduated from the University of
Nottingham though getting the work visa
will be tough here Johan demonstrates
virtual reality applications for cars
here we have a virtual reality project
that we're doing with Jaguar Land Rover
so two people in very geographical
remote locations can look at the data
assets in real time and manipulate them
pala vs. core business is creating
software for the automotive industry but
the company also works in the
entertainment field and has created
programs for amusement parks and arcades
so it appreciates being part of the EU
we like open market we like the free
movement of labour we like the ability
to expand in a way where we are not
burdened by regulation which we
currently are not too burdened by most
British businesspeople feel the same way
but will they be leading the charge in
the brexit debate Britons are set to
vote on the matter in a referendum to be
held by 2017 at the latest
what people think about a lot certainly
in our workforce is whether their
employment is secure and whether they
can afford to run their household
budgets and run their their own lives
and the EU doesn't impinge on that in
any particular way so I don't think that
people are qualities exercised at the
personal level about this recent polls
found that nearly half of Britain's
favorite brexit so the nation's
entrepreneurs will need to convince
people and not just in the town of rugby
of the benefits of staying in the Common
Market